des rêves qu'on pourrait contrôler des
rêves où on a conscience d'être à
l'intérieur d'un rêve c'est encore mieux
que la VR ça s'appelle les rêves lucides
salut je vous en ai déjà parlé des rêves
lucides il y a des années voici une
sorte de compilation mise à jour de
comment faire des rêves lucides on passe
en moyenne 50 notre vie à rêver pour une
moyenne de 100000 rêves si vous pouviez
faire tout ce que vous voulez dans
certains d'entre eux ça vous motiverait
peut-être aller vous coucher moi par
exemple j'ai rêvé que cette vidéo était
sponsorisée bon pas laissez-moi vous
informer que c'est le cas et par Odou
parce que même si là on s'apprête à
parler des rêves lucides que
penseriez-vous d'être accompagné pour
réaliser vos projets de rêve vos projets
de rêve lucides enfin bon projet lucide
hein pas vos rêves vous me suivez par
exemple si vous voulez vous lancer dans
le e-commerce Audoux peut vous
accompagner sur de nombreux plans peau
douce et un logiciel tout en un qui
offre un éventail d'application pour les
entrepreneurs et PME qui veulent se
faciliter la gestion de leur diverses
tâches dans le quotidien vous pouvez
lancer votre boutique en ligne
facilement en quelques clics Audoux va
vous guider pas à pas pour réaliser
votre projet et c'est vraiment vraiment
fluide la plateforme est ultra intuitive
il vous suffit de créer votre site
ajuster vos produits tout est
personnalisable selon vos envies vos
besoins et voilà c'est fait vous êtes
prêts à réaliser vos premières ventes
tout ça est gratuit parce que la
première application est offerte à vie
chez audio donc n'hésitez pas vous
pouvez foncer vous pouvez aussi
découvrir leurs services via le lien qui
est disponible dans la description donc
nous on s'apprêtait à transformer vos
rêves en rêve lucides mais avant les
rêves lucides c'est quoi les rêves
lucides ça dure pas très longtemps et le
contrôle qu'on a sur eux c'est pas
permanent et c'est pas automatique en
général un rêve lucide c'est entouré de
deux rêves normaux durant la phase de
sommeil paradoxal donc un rêve où on
contrôler rien qui bascule en rêve
lucide on a conscience d'être dans le
raid et qui repassent après en rêve ou
en contrôle pas en gros aujourd'hui on
en est sûr on ne peut pas passer lui
entière à être lucide dans nos rêves il
y a trois types de rêveurs lucides le
premier type c'est juste celui qui nous
donne la capacité de nous réveiller
quand on veut donc on a aucun contrôle
sur rien mais à un moment donné par
exemple on a peur d'un cauchemar et on
se dit je veux me réveiller hop on se
réveille c'est une forme de lucidité
après il y a celui où on est spectateur
de notre rêve donc on n'a pas décidé du
décor on n'a pas décidé du scénario mais
on a l'impression de pouvoir prendre des
décisions dans notre rêve c'est à dire
d'aller à droite ou d'aller à gauche ou
alors on suit le Sénart mais on a juste
conscience qu'on est dans un rêve et le
stade ultime même s'il y a des petites
nuances de stade entre les deux c'est
celui où on est omnipotent on peut
décider du décor on peut décider de
transgresser par exemple les lois
universelles on peut voler par exemple
on peut décider de tout il y a deux
choses très importantes à savoir sur les
rêves lucides d'abord ce sont pas
forcément des rêves de dingue genre film
d'action ou de super-héros c'est même
souvent des scènes assez simples où vous
êtes en train de résoudre un problème
par exemple vous êtes en train de manger
avec votre meilleur pote dans une
cuisine il y a plus rien dans le frigo
il faut trouver quoi faire à manger
voilà c'est relativement simple faut pas
s'attendre à avoir des choses
incroyables à raconter le deuxième point
c'est qu'il est fort probable que vous
ayez tous déjà fait des rêves lucides
dans votre vie seulement vous vous en
souvenez plus ça c'est un petit peu
comme comme les personnes qui disent moi
je rêve jamais sauf très rares cas la
majorité du temps ce sont des personnes
qui rêvent juste elles se souviennent
plus de leurs rêves à leur réveil parce
que le rêve il est fait pour être évacué
c'est un peu comme chez les animaux
c'est pour pas fondre en fait ce qui se
passe dans le monde onirique de ce qui
se passe dans la réalité tu imagines si
ton chien quand il rêve il est en train
de courser à lapin au moment où il ouvre
les yeux il cherche le lapin dans toute
la baraque sur le canapé qui fait tout
tomber ce serait un problème donc le
rêve est fait pour être évacué assez
rapidement on reprend conscience quand
on se réveille je vais maintenant vous
donner des techniques pour réussir à
faire des rêves lucides et surtout pour
vous rappeler de ses rêves même si on
est légitime à se poser la question ça
sert à quoi de faire un rêve lucide déjà
ça sert à qui fait en vrai c'est marrant
mais ça peut être utile à trois autres
choses déjà à faire face au cauchemar
dans un état de conscience même peut
élever une personne qui se retrouve en
plein cauchemar peut très bien
interrompre son rêve et se réveiller
pour en sortir ça c'est cool la deuxième
chose c'est que ça sert aussi à gérer
des stress post-traumatiques ou futurs
parce qu'on peut un peu réécrire
l'histoire et quand je dis future c'est
un peu le troisième point ça sert aussi
expérimenter des choses dites vous que
votre cerveau il connaît toutes les
règles de la physique il connaît les
règles de notre réalité et donc si vous
expérimentez par exemple un saut en
parachute dans un rêve lucide il y a de
fortes chances pour que les que vous
vivrez ressemble aux sensations de la
réalité c'est-à-dire la force du vent
comme ça etc etc ça se rapproche souvent
quand même du réel il n'empêche
qu'aujourd'hui le fait de rêver ça reste
un mystère pour la science et il y a
beaucoup de neurophysiciens qui tentent
de comprendre ce qui se produit dans
notre cerveau surtout quand on fait des
rêves lucides parce que quand on est en
rêve Lucie de la zone de notre cerveau
qui active notre sens critique notre
conscience de nous-même aller légèrement
activer elle aussi durant très longtemps
on pensait que les rêves lucides
n'existaient pas c'est à dire qu'on
rêvait qu'on faisait un rêve lucide vous
voyez le truc c'est un petit peu méta
mais mais pas qu'on faisait
littéralement un rêve lucide parce qu'il
faut avoir son sens critique sa
conscience de soi et on s'est aperçu ces
dernières années que si ça cette zone là
était légèrement active celle-ci est
aussi le siège de la métacognition ce
qui nous permet d'avoir des pensées sur
nos propres pensées toutes ces zones
normalement inaccessibles d'un rêve
classique s'active lors d'un rêve lucide
c'est donc une véritable conscience qui
s'installe à l'intérieur et aujourd'hui
tous les scientifiques essaient de mieux
comprendre ce phénomène alors j'ai fait
plusieurs vidéos sur le sujet des rêves
lu et je vous les mettrai dans la
description parce que j'ai commencé à
faire des vidéos sur le sujet en 2016 au
fur et à mesure ça s'est complété
parfois ça s'est amélioré j'ai donné les
avancées de la science des techniques en
faire mieux là je vous fais une compile
des techniques qui fonctionnent le mieux
pour faire un rêve lucide et je vous ai
sélectionné des méthodes qui prennent
pas beaucoup de temps dans la vie
quotidienne mais qui ne demande quand
même un certain investissement
d'ailleurs je vous le dis tout de suite
soyez patient c'est pas des méthodes
miracles parce que parce que il y en a
pas on va il y a aucune méthode qui peut
être bonne si elle est pas pratiquée
régulièrement donc n'hésitez pas à
répéter ça sur plusieurs jours voir sur
plusieurs semaines ça viendra pas tout
de suite et vous savez il y a des gens
qui disent moi je fais des rêves lucides
tous les soirs etc la plupart du temps
c'est pas vrai on dit un bon rêveur
lucide il fait 2 3 4ème le site dans le
mois grand maximum il y a encore trois
quatre mucides dont il se rappelle alors
la première astuce c'est de s'imprégner
du sujet des rêves vous êtes
littéralement en train de vous imprégner
de la thématique du rêve en regardant
cette vidéo parce que on est en train de
d'en parler donc ça va ça va rester dans
une mémoire épisodique qui va être relu
en boucle dans l'hippocampe dans la
journée et dans la nuit
des articles sur le sujet vous pouvez
simplement y penser et réfléchir bref
prenez conscience que vous êtes une
personne qui rêve toutes les nuits et
accorder du temps à ce rêve quand on
dort le cerveau va traiter des infos
qu'il a engrangé toute la journée
l'inconscient en fera plus facilement un
rebond là-dessus puisque vous serez
nourri de la thématique du rêve deuxième
astuce c'est au coucher donnez-vous un
ordre clair au moment de vous coucher
gravé dans votre inconscient que vous
voulez faire un réussite par exemple
vous pouvez répéter en boucle la phrase
suivante la prochaine fois que je vais
rêver je vais prendre conscience que je
rêve vous vous dites ça comme ça
intérieurement ça envoie un message très
fort un inconscient vous envoyer une
sorte de désir une démarche claire à
votre cerveau qui va probablement le
prendre en compte c'est aussi quelque
chose que vous pouvez faire au milieu de
la nuit je vous disais que c'était lors
du sommeil paradoxal qu'on avait des
chances de faire un rêve lucide donc
vous pouvez mettre un réveil quand vous
estimez que ça fait 5 heures que vous
dormez ou qui vous reste plus que deux
heures ensuite par exemple si vous
couchez à minuit vous mettez un réveil à
5h du matin quand le réveil va sonner
vous l'éteignez vous essayez de vous
rendormir
répétant la fameuse phase la prochaine
fois que je rêve je veux avoir
conscience que je rêve dans mon rêve par
exemple c'est une technique très
efficace comme le fait de Jupiter c'est
me connaissez pas le mot jupe jeté c'est
un néologisme c'est un mot qui n'existe
pas vraiment c'est le fait de retourner
dans sa rêve qu'on a déjà fait par
exemple on se réveille et on essaie de
retourner dans ce rêve parce qu'on a
bien aimé bah on peut faire un dérivé de
ça ça peut être une astuce avant de
s'endormir le soir on aime bien à se
faire des petits scénars dans sa tête et
bien imaginez les yeux fermés que vous
avez vos bras devant vous vous baissez
les yeux mentalement bien sûr vous voyez
vos pieds en fait vous voyez tout comme
quand vous êtes réveillé et qu'on est
réveillé on peut voir ses bras on peut
voir ses jambes on peut même voir son
nez qui nous cache une partie du regard
je sais que là il y en a qui sont en
train de bugger loucher de se dire mais
c'est vrai que je vois mon nez en fait
on est à notre nez littéralement au
milieu de notre regard toute la journée
et on en a pas conscience et bien vous
les yeux fermés vous pouvez imaginer en
fait voir vos bras vos jambes mais aussi
votre nez dans votre vision l'idée qu'on
fait un rêve lucide c'est de pas rêver à
la troisième personne souvent on rêve à
la troisième d'autres personnes on se
voit à l'extérieur c'est mon cas où je
sais pas si c'est votre cas dites-le-moi
je serai assez curieux de voir on va
sonder un petit peu est-ce que vous
réveiller à la première personne c'est à
dire vous voyez à travers vos yeux ou
est-ce que vous voyez la scène de
l'extérieur et vous vous voyez vous
depuis l'extérieur ça m'intéresserait
vraiment de savoir mais le faiter que
pour faire des rêves lucides il faut se
réhabituer il faut habituer son cerveau
à s'imaginer nous-mêmes à la première
personne autre astuce mais vraiment
essentielle faites appel à votre mémoire
quand vous vous réveillez le matin ne
vous jetez pas sur votre téléphone elle
met pas la radio prenez le temps déjà
avant d'ouvrir les yeux prenez le temps
de vous retrouver des mergets de prendre
le temps de de vous rappeler un petit
peu des petits bouts de rêve parfois si
vous retrouvez un élément du rêve c'est
comme une espèce de de fil d'une énorme
pelote de laine que vous allez pouvoir
dérouler tout votre rêve va vous revenir
donc prenez le temps de réapprécier tout
ça et aller chercher le détail de ce que
vous avez rêvé une fois que c'est fait
prenez un carnet un crayon que vous
aurez déposé à l'avance à côté de votre
lit et notez vos rêves même si c'est pas
des rêves lucides notez vos rêves pour
réhabituer en fait ce qu'on pas la
mémoire onirique le fait de se souvenir
de ses rêves la règle c'est quoi qu'il
arrive qu'on se réveille de ne pas
chercher à les capter des nouvelles
informations extérieures à soi-même ou
de provoquer des stimuli cérébraux mais
le fait que souvent on pense qu'on se
souvienne pas de nos rêves parce qu'on a
enchaîné trop vite et surtout parce
qu'on n'a pas cherché à s'en souvenir
donc prenez le réflexe tous les matins
d'essayer d'obtenir ne serait-ce qu'une
image un mot une sensation quelque chose
comme ça de l'un de vos rêves de la nuit
la meilleure astuce que je peux vous
recommander c'est le test de réalité si
vous intéresse ce sujet vous avez
sûrement déjà entendu parler ça du test
de réalité je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure quand vous dormez votre esprit
critique il s'endort aussi et c'est à ça
que va servir le test de réalité pour
savoir si vous rêvez ou si vous êtes
dans la réalité en gros la journée vous
remettez pas en cause la réalité parce
que votre esprit critique est activé et
donc il voit que tout est cohérent tout
est logique la nuit quand vous dormez ça
ça se débranche donc il y a des choses
incroyables qui se passent autour de
vous mais comme il n'y a pas l'esprit
critique pour vous c'est la réalité
c'est sûr le moment où vous rêvez vous
ne remettez pas en cause ça le test de
réalité va permettre d'activer le sens
critique et de se demander en permanence
si c'est normal ou si c'est pas normal
ces tests de réalité je vais vous donner
des exemples à vous inquiétez pas vous
allez les faire régulièrement dans votre
journée à des moments précis et à force
de le faire ça va devenir une habitude
et cette habitude vous risquez de la
prendre aussi dans votre rêve et c'est
le but qui recherchait c'est que si vous
prenez par exemple toujours l'habitude
de compter sur vos doigts vous faites un
deux trois quatre cinq vous vérifiez que
vous avez bien 5 doigts vous vous
demandez d'où vous venez où est-ce que
vous allez et si tout ce que vous voyez
est cohérent en fait ça plusieurs fois
par jour ça augmente les chances que
vous fassiez la même chose dans un rêve
et que vous comptiez sur vos doigts et
que il y en ait en plus ou peut-être pas
assez et après quand vous allez vous
poser les questions de où est-ce que je
viens ou est-ce que je vais est-ce que
tout est cohérent peut-être c'est là où
vous allez prendre conscience que je ne
sais pas tout bien je sais pas où je
vais et non c'est pas tout à fait normal
que je sois sur la lune actuellement il
y a d'autres tests de réalité qui sont
possibles comme essayer de respirer en
se bouchant le nez et la bouche si vous
bougez tout ça
vous arrivez à respirer c'est clairement
un rêve et si vous le faites dans un
rêve vous allez réussir à respirer et là
vous allez vous dire ok je suis dans un
rêve et vous aurez réussi à force
d'observer mes rêves je me suis rendu
compte que souvent je rentrais quelque
part donc l'habitude que j'ai prise
c'est qu'à chaque fois que je rentre
quelque part ou que je franchis une
porte je me fais un test de réalité et
j'essaie d'être critique sur la réalité
qui m'entoure pour voir si je suis dans
la réalité ou dans un rêve et ça ça a
augmenté mes chances de faire des rêves
lucides donc en réalité il y a quand
même de fortes chances que vous soyez
lucide dans un rêve mais peut-être que
quelques instants mais surtout quand ça
va vous arriver surtout les premières
fois vous avez tellement excité ou
stressé parce qu'il va se passer par la
prise de conscience que votre coeur va
s'accélérer et que vous allez vous
réveiller c'est dommage mais je vous
rassure ça fait ça à tout le monde pour
essayer de rester dans le rêve en
restant lucide vous pouvez par exemple
créer un personnage fictif qui va venir
vous rassurer et qui va vous calmer ça
peut être votre voisin votre chanteur
préféré ça peut être moi je l'ai fait
dans une vidéo ça y est ça avait marché
pour pour pas mal d'entre vous et peu
importe ce personnage fictif quand vous
allez vous coucher vous allez l'imaginer
en train de vous dire dire que tout va
bien t'inquiète pas tu es dans un rêve
lucide vous vous faites ce fantasme là
dans votre tête et c'est quelque chose
qui va sans créer dans votre mémoire et
qui a de grandes chances de s'activer au
moment où vous ferez un rêve lucide et
de ce matérialiser et donc ça va vous
calmer vraiment consciemment vous aurez
créer votre votre personnage imaginaire
on récapitule vite fait imprégnez-vous
du sujet des rêves en regardant des
vidéos lisant des textes regardez
Inception par exemple donner l'ordre à
votre cerveau que vous voulez avoir
conscience que vous rêvez quand vous
rêvez Faites des tests de réalité au fur
et à mesure de la journée vous prenez le
test qui vous convient le mieux vous
pourrez faire des tests là-dessus vous
le faites plusieurs fois par jour et
vous notez vos rêves dès votre réveil
petite astuce supplémentaire évitez de
consommer de l'alcool éviter d'avoir des
grosses carences de sommeil en gros
essayez d'avoir un corps sain et un
cerveau sain pour pour essayer de faire
ces rêves lucides donc mettez toutes les
chances de votre côté en faisant ça un
peu comme un sportif ça fait bien
longtemps que j'avais pas parlé des
rêves lucides donc je me suis dit si
jamais j'en reparle il faut que je
commence comme ça par une vidéo un petit
peu de la base qui reprend tous les
essentiels qui sont à jour aujourd'hui
mais si ça vous intéresse que je rentre
un petit peu plus dans le détail que ce
soit dans dans la science ou dans les
techniques ou dans ce qu'on peut faire
dans les rêves n'hésitez pas à m'en
parler dans les commentaires je serai
ravi de continuer de partager ça avec
vous ça faisait longtemps que je l'avais
pas fait aussi parce que comme j'avais
fait 4-5 vidéos je vous rappelle je les
mets en description j'avais l'impression
que j'avais un peu essoré le sujet et
que j'allais tourner en rond vous en
parler mais je me rends compte que ces
vidéos sont tellement vieilles que si
vous connaissez ma chaîne depuis 2 ans
vous m'avez jamais entendu parler de ça
et merci aussi à Odou d'avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à les
découvrir leurs services qui sont très
qualitatifs il y a le lien dans la
description et surtout surtout faites de
beaux rêves à très bientôt Ciao